[Música]
diez mujeres han sido asesinadas por
feminicidas en Colombia en lo que va del
2023 los casos van desde historias como
la de María Camila plazas de diez años
que falleció tras defenderse de una
violación hasta ladilla y Valentina tres
Palacios torturada y asesinada por su
pareja el estadounidense John polos los
llamados crecen para que sea declarada
una emergencia por violencia de género
en el país mientras en la conversación
diaria Aún se impone responsabilizar a
las que Perdieron su vida La culpa es
del machismo y sobre eso vamos a
conversar con yamiles roncancio ella es
abogada y directora de la fundación de
feminicidios Colombia yamile Gracias
bienvenida Hola Muchas gracias por la
invitación vamos a comenzar hablando del
discurso que se maneja el
sensacionalismo y la revictimización son
prácticamente las reglas tanto en los
medios de comunicación como en las redes
sociales Así que vamos a empezar con el
caso que más suena en este momento en
Colombia que hay que decirlo está en las
portadas por una madre muy valiente que
se riesgo propio para dar declaraciones
Valentina tres Palacios fue asesinada
por un novio extranjero pero ahora
resulta que la culpa es de ella por qué
Ese es el discurso que domina la
discusión bueno porque es el que más
atrae tráfico en las páginas de
información no a la gente en Colombia la
mueve sobre todo el morbo saber que era
lo que pasaba específicamente con la
vida de ella y Porque además como hay un
marcado uso de la palabra celos en los
feminicidios cuando hay celos La
pregunta es qué hizo ella para generar
los celos entonces empieza esta búsqueda
exhaustiva de cuántos novios tuvo Cómo
eran los novios es decir buscar alguna
justificación para el feminicida así la
prensa No piense que esa va a ser Pues
digamos en la finalidad si se va
generando y además porque entre más
historias salgan de ahí pues más tráfico
de información va a tener el riesgo Pues
de las víctimas Aunque ya no esté pues
merece respeto su memoria fíjese que
ayer leía un artículo de un medio
internacional que contaba como John
Paulo se le enviaba dinero con
regularidad y se pudo hacer cirugías Y
entonces claro aumentó su belleza con el
paso del tiempo y bueno todo esto se
volvió un espectáculo en vez del
discurso que solamente tendría que
pertenecerle a la víctima y además
yamile este caso corre peligro de quedar
en la impunidad un ejemplo más de un
sistema judicial que usted conoce muy
bien que no está preparado para atender
la violencia de género que no entiende
el feminicidio y que además es
ineficiente podríamos quedarnos sin caso
por el simple hecho de que no hay
traductores que puedan tratar
adecuadamente las audiencias sí es un
asunto aterrador porque Además creo que
nos Toma por sorpresa o le tomó al
sistema por sorpresa este caso eso no es
habitual en Colombia no es habitual que
el feminicida tenga otro otro idioma y
bueno ayer se empezó a solventar de
mejor manera pero fíjate que el tema de
la Traducción también es una muestra de
la misoginia yo ayer estaba viendo la
audiencia y el traductor estaba
cometiendo errores constantes pero ahí
no hubo memes en contra el traductor en
cambio en contra de la mujer que había
sido traductora Sí y el sistema judicial
lo ve es simplemente como un caso
emblemático en el que no hay mucho
cuidado porque reaccionan muy rápido y
se cometen errores procedimentales lo
que han venido advirtiendo los abogados
penalistas Y nosotras es que puede haber
una nulidad posterior dentro del proceso
que haría tambalear Pues digamos al
menos este inicio pero yo espero que
haya una sentencia pronto y espero
también de él un poco de sensatez con el
paso de los días para llevarlo a aceptar
cargos Aunque es poco difícil Mira es
una tristeza que pese el histórico caso
de Rosa Celis que nos trajo a Colombia
la ley contra el feminicidio y las
medidas contra el feminicidio aún haya
tantos vacíos en los temas de género y
eso me lleva a hablarle del otro caso
que suena mucho en Colombia tristemente
por estos días y es el de María Camila
diez años de edad su feminicida entra a
su vivienda intenta violarla ella se
defiende termina ella muerta y su abuela
herida de gravedad y en un hospital este
tipo acaba de salir de la cárcel pero el
mundo nos sigue diciendo que somos
nosotras las que tenemos que cuidarnos
tener miedo protegernos prevenir
nuestros propios feminicidios y nuestras
propias violaciones en este caso era una
niña que estaba en su casa jugando
entonces del feminicida no se habla sí
exacto y aquí es muy curioso que la
prensa y si no ha escudriñado En cuál
era el caso anterior por el que había
sido sancionado Y qué fue lo que pasó en
el trámite de ese caso y porque una
sentencia tan corta porque lo que se ha
visto era que llevaba muy poco tiempo en
la cárcel es un hombre muy joven Pero
además una cosa lo imputaron como un
homicidio es decir nosotras nos
enteramos en la noche y reaccionamos muy
rápido contactando a la fiscalía general
que ya se supone que convocó a una mesa
de trabajo
aproximadamente no aceptó cargos Porque
si los hubiera aceptado hubiera sido muy
difícil el cambio feminicidio que se
está exigiendo pero en ese nivel está
todavía la fiscalía o sea Es evidente
que es un feminicidio con ronda niña y
lo imputaron como un homicidio en la
primera medida Entonces es aterrador y
no se le hace seguimiento a los
violadores cuando salen de las cárceles
Y eso sí es una ausencia muy grave en la
legislación colombiana además de esta
tendencia demostrar la foto de María
Camila en todas partes y del feminicida
si he visto solamente una imagen de él y
esta es una tendencia típica en Colombia
que pareciera que la mayoría de medios
de comunicación no entiende que en el
código de infancia y adolescencia y una
norma específica que les prohíbe hacer
eso no pero como estas familias están
sumergidas en un asunto Pues de el
proceso judicial no van a tener el
tiempo para empezar a presentar tutelas
para que bajen la foto de María Camila
porque quien dispone de la imagen de
ella así ya esté muerta es su familia
porque era una niña no obstante Pues los
medios lo que hicieron fue Mostrar esta
foto recurrentemente como lo que pasó el
año pasado con la niña que fue asesinada
la niña de ocho años también
ahora por qué cree ustedes que es
necesario que se declaré una emergencia
basada en género el año pasado fueron
más de 600 feminicidios registrados de
los que se tenga conocimiento en
Colombia y cree usted que se lo debemos
a por ejemplo Jared pomares Angélica
Trejo a Melissa toro gallina Bocanegra a
tantas más que fallecen todos los días
Bueno realmente nosotras no estamos muy
de acuerdo con que se ha declarado como
una emergencia porque las emergencias
son abordadas como emergencia como
cuando hay un desastre natural no y se
toman decisiones muy rápidas que quedan
como decisiones rápidas Esto no es una
novedad para nosotras tú lo sabes
llevamos años hablando de esto entonces
lo que se necesita es una política
pública bien implementada pero claro
esta tensión social hace que se piensen
desde el mejor de los deseos Pues que
una emergencia o una alerta soluciona y
lo que se necesita es expertas ayudando
al gobierno para tomar las mejores
decisiones y empezar Pues a mirar el
feminicidio como un asunto complejo
sistémico y no Simplemente con capturo
sanciono y se acabó no la idea es que no
haya feminicidio y la visión tiene que
modificarse allí pero todavía ni
siquiera se entiende Lo que es un
feminicidio nos queda menos de un minuto
y quiero cerrar esta entrevista
preguntándole por lo que nos enseñan las
mujeres y lo que les enseñan a los
hombres las mujeres que crecen teniendo
miedo y los hombres con masculinidades
tóxicas sí sobre todo con la temeridad
Es decir desde niños les están diciendo
Tú puedes hacer lo que tú quieras tú
puedes absolutamente con todo y los
retos desde niños es poner en riesgo su
vida y la de otros Entonces desde niños
están siendo educados para tomar
acciones pues muy
accidentadas temerosas y bueno eso se
convierte cuando son grandes en hacer lo
que ellos consideren que es mejor y lo
que es su derecho los feminicidas
piensan que ese era su derecho matar a
las mujeres